[Musik]
eine eisgrotte eine begehbare skulptur
aus gefrorenem wasser landschaftskunst
meint man ein spiel mit den launen der
natur
architekt konrad dem klub ort
begutachtet wie sein eisgebilde auf dem
geflecht von weidenruten wächst
eine zuleitung bringt schmelzwasser vom
ortsrat gletscher in einen sprinkler der
es als schnee staub wieder ausstößt und
so den eispalast schicht um schicht
wachsen lässt
die inspiration dazu stammt aus asien
in 2015 bin ich mit minute durch
studenten in ladakh sich das in
nordindien in einer bürste region enorm
vom himalaya 1 360 tage trocken
niederschläge nur gletscher ins wasser
erst im juni und den das system oder
kunden mit sogenannten super bauer aus
schmelzwasser recyceln projekt was ich
ein riesiges berger bauer zum im
frühling schmelzwasser generiere für
ihre ecken mit dieser einfachen methode
etwas gegen wasserknappheit zu tun und
gleichzeitig fantastisches räume zu
gestalten
das fasziniert den architekten deshalb
brachte er die idee in die schweiz
in dieser künstlichen erscheinungsform
wirkt eis filigran verletzlich irgendwie
fast möchte man es schützen und bewahren
das recycling prinzip der eystruper hat
den glaziologen felix keller auf den
plan gerufen er allerdings will das
schmelzwasser nicht für eyes to pass und
bewässerung nutzen sondern es dem
gletscher wieder zurückgeben
diese idee ist sehr sehr ähnlich nämlich
dass im schmelzwasser brucker türen um
schnittstelle ohne die isa zwei
elektrische energie und dort mit skis
vor dem schmelzen schützend damit
marktsprecher fünfte generation erhalten
kellers plan konkret
er will das tausendfache an
schmelzwasser auffangen im oberen teil
des gletschers
um es weiter unten großflächig zur
beschneiung einzusetzen
so ließ er sich der schrumpfendem auf
derart gletscher langfristig
stabilisieren für diese vision wirbt die
eystruper bei pontresina mit verspieltem
reiz und kühlen charme
[Musik]